donc le vrai faux du coran d'un virus on
pourra avoir de gros problèmes
d'internet à cause du confinement
c'est vrai parce qu'en fait le réseau
téléphonique internet ils vont être
saturés alors ils ont demandé le
gouvernement a demandé en fin ou les
opérateurs on dit qu'il valait mieux
quand on était chez soi se mettre sur le
réseau plutôt que d'utiliser la 4g ou
l'asthme ou la 3g éventuellement parce
que le réseau fonctionne sur le fixe et
donc ça sature - mais c'est vrai qu'on
risque de faire saturer les opérateurs
de nombreux français vont encore boire
des verres dans les bars et les
restaurants vrai ou faux je n'ai pas vu
tout est fermé non toutes les rumeurs
qui l'annoncent d'edouard philippe
samedi ça n'empêche pas certains de
trouver des solutions et de trinquer
chez eux tranquillou regardez ce garçon
même sans âme ni même sans famille il
simplifie traque tout seul regarde c'est
parti voilà tranquille ça le style du
désespéré sion il est interdit de faire
ses courses après 18 heures vrai ou faux
totalement faux ces fausses et il n'y a
pas de couvre-feu l'heure actuelle
d'accord donc ya pas de couvre-feu
nantis mais tranquille tient question
également vrai ou faux en france il
était conseillé de se faire des amis
depuis son balcon pendant la période de
confinement non c'est faux aussi alors
que son vrai nom mais pourquoi
independent là c'est vrai si éviter de
vous faire des potes depuis votre wagon
il y à une vidéo je vous le dis qui m'a
fait la journée je les ai vus sur les
réseaux regarder on y voit une
discussion par fenêtre interposés un
gars poser une question à d'autres je
vous jure j'en ai pleuré de rire
regardez ce à quoi je pousse mais on n'a
pas entendu on a rien à attendre
ll est très drôle ils ont coupé il au
coupé de retomber saillie il monte mal
les gars quand je vous dis que c'est pas
le monde vouloir se faire des potes
depuis votre balcon je ne dois pas
regardez ce qui est arrivé
un joueur de foot cheikh fabregas le
milieu de terrain de l'as monaco il a
voulu dire bonjour depuis sa terrasse et
s'est pris un gros taquet par un de ses
voisins regardent et goûtent bonne
humeur voilà oui pas et s'est fait
insulter depuis son balcon trop qui voit
là mais c'est marrant il ya une autre
vidéo que je voulais vous montrer
j'ai vu sur tik tok ce matin voilà
tictoc savais que je le lâche pas vous
allez voir
le conseil est le même pour tout le
monde restez chez vous regardez ça
[Musique]
il ya des vidéos incroyables
en ce moment c'est super tu vois garder
le sens de l'humour il ya plein de dates
qui circulent à nice est génial ça
détend il y en a même qui ont réussi à
se faire des potes depuis leur balcon
mais pas en france en espagne
visiblement ça marche des habitants
confiné jo bingo ou encore à la bataille
navale depuis leur balcon regarder ça à
regarder
intego cité cote aaa
ici c'est magique
alors y'a et on est dans le vrai fondu
coronavirus que vous attendez tous les
soirs vrai ou faux il est possible de se
créer un masque de protection avec ses
chaussures vrai ou faux faux faux séné
dans le micro mais non c'est pas
intelligent c'est pas intelligent alors
c'est pas bon mais déjà rien que l'odeur
déjà ça serait ça serait compliqué je
vous dis mais sur tik tok
j'ai vu une rigolade je voulais vous
montrer ce soir ce sont vraiment des
oufs dans le monde qui sont créés des
masques
regardez ils se créent des masques avec
n'importe quoi regarder ça le rire est
magique et o'keefe est tabou qui fait
avec nous en direct à l'astronaute
thomas pesquet a tourné un tuto
confinement après avoir passé sept mois
en orbite
ouais c'était vraiment intéressant son
tutorat il explique comment il s'est
débrouillé à vivre quasiment en
confinement pendant beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus longtemps que nous le fait
que nous on a la chance de pouvoir jeter
les détritus de nourriture dans une
poubelle alors que lui ça se balade dans
l'air son sac de couchage dans lequel il
ya dormi et il a montré qu'en fait en
lisant il faisait des choses formidables
regarder thomas pasquet nous a donné des
petits et petits conseils sa vidéo
leakée 35 mille fois regardé fait quoi
un astronaute quand c'est bloqué chez
soi
moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir remplir
quelques unes de mes tâches depuis la
maison mais ça va notamment me permettre
de trier peut-être un peu plus mes
photos qui me reste de la mission est de
les poster un peu plus régulièrement sur
les réseaux sociaux ont pour le
ravitaillement pattani qu'on risque pas
à pénuries alimentaires toute façon dans
la nourriture en boîte
j'ai l'habitude et puis au moins ici
reste dans l'assiette
pour me rappeler les bons souvenirs de
la station spatiale j'ai même installé
un du vertical
j'ai dormi là dedans pendant six mois
donc c'est pas quelques semaines
d'isolement qui ont faire peur blague à
part le message à retenir c'est qu'il
faut absolument éviter la propagation du
virus
restez chez vous restez chez vous tiens
y'a nyala et à la responsable des sports
de levallois qui m'envoient c'est un
message qui me dit vraiment aux mêmes
dans leur vie ils voient trop
d'incivilités les gens sortent encore
beaucoup trop je vous le dis les chéris
restez chez vous apprendra de semaine
trois semaines marc on pourra sortir
faire des dark a rigolé qui fait
ensemble
mais là les cherry pour l'instant
vraiment ne sortait pas et je le dis
autant pour les personnes plus jeunes
que pour les personnes plus âgées parce
que y en a aussi qui veulent jouer les
rebelles c'est pas le moment de jouer
les rebelles là c'est vraiment on n'est
pas là dedans
vraiment on pense non seulement à soi
mais on pense aussi aux autres je vous
le demande
restez chez vous il ya encore beaucoup
trop de gens dans la rue encore alors
mon petit neveu qu'on arrête pas qu'on
n'arrive pas à arrêter de sortir en
général dit que c'est trop super cette
émission parce qu'ils te regarde et dit
que jonathan il est en même temps dans
le salon avec toi d'en bas très bas qui
viennent avec voilà c'est mieux voilà
les chéris eric zemmour a suggéré au
président macron de renommer le
coronavirus le corinna virus bien sûr
c'est faux c'est une vanne merci au
revoir
en pleine période de confinement on a vu
des dinosaures se balader dans les rues
vrai ou faux nom et si les très riches
ici si on a vu des situations de fou
comme la réapparition des dinosaures
regardez
[Musique]
il
voilà on voit on voit plein de trucs
complètement fous et voilà je vous le
dis ça se passait en catalogne question
vrai ou faux
nos corps vrai ou faux question on voit
là c'est la question celle ci c'est
celle ci je voulais ce midi doc gynéco
c'était contrôlé avec 2 4 g de gel hydro
alcoolique dans le sang vrai ou faux
c'est faux mais on embrasse donc on
espère qu'il va bien mon chéri d'amour
parce que jérôme alors j'aimerais bien
qu'il aille à aux vrais ou faux on a vu
isabelle morini-bosc prendre l'air
pendant le confinement mont isa oui oui
mais regardez on a les images regarder
isabelle qui a pris l'air notre chéri
d'isabelle morini-bosc de touche pas à
mon poste voilà
et apparemment elle va bien est ce que
c'est dangereux c'est de faire salon de
rien ou bien s'ils n'entendent pas du
balcon c'est pas dangereux si on tombe
pas du mal qu'on sait c'est plutôt ça a
été plutôt sympathique vrai ou faux pour
se protéger non c'est pas ça là que je
voulais vrai ou faux une nouvelle
technique va révolutionner la drac
pendant le confinement ben il faut la
donner à sydney la région de bajur here
we puisque tout le monde entend
confinement on se demande tous comment
on va s'occuper
eh bien figurez-vous que netflix a
développé une extension qui risque de
révolutionner le monde de la drague
pendant le confinement ça s'appelle
netflix partie en gros pendant que vous
mettez un film ou une série sur l'autre
sur votre plateforme
vous pouvez vous connecter en même temps
avec d'autres utilisateurs pour voir la
même chose il ya même un chat qui permet
d'échanger donc vous voilà vous fait
d'avoir fait des commentaires sur la
syrie tout ça ça permet de ce qui fait
le jeu vous dit et ça c'est pas mal ça
va révolutionner en france il est
actuellement interdit de se rendre à un
enterrement
vrai ou faux alain enfaux des
funérailles sont maintenues mais un tout
petit nombre de personnes
et c'est que la famille les amis même
les amis n'ont pas le droit d'aller
alors ça c'est pas la réponse d'edouard
philippe puisqu'il ya un an dans ce vrai
il a bien dit des amis n'ont pas le
droit mais la famille intime et en se
maintenant à distance oui alors hier le
premier ministre était invitée du jt de
20h sur france 2 et une téléspectatrice
lui a demandé si elle pouvait se rendre
à l'enterrement de son ami décédé 48
heures plus tôt et vous allez voir la
réponse d'edouard philippe tout le monde
en a parlé il a été clair précis et sans
équivoque regarde nami est décédé il y à
48 heures avant nous le droit de nous
rendre à son enterrement
ce que je veux dire est terrible à
entendre pour pour la téléspectatrice
qui pose cette question
mais je me dois d'être à la hauteur des
fonctions que j'occupe et donc je vais
répondre non nous ne devons pas nous
devons limiter au maximum les
déplacements et même dans cette
circonstance et j'ai bien conscience de
dire quelque chose d'une très grande
dureté
même dans ces circonstances nous ne
devons pas dérogé à la règle qui a été
fixée je le dis avec eux avec une une
grande tristesse mais aussi avec une
très grande détermination
voilà alors il a été clair là dessus je
vous remercie sydney ohana et jean
michel cohen d'avoir été avec nous dans
un instant je répondre à cette question
les boulangeries seront fermés pour
éviter la transmission du coronavirus
vrai ou faux dans un instant jours et si
mon pote hugot clément
voilà qui va nous parler parce qu'il a
un petit message de nous faire passer
j'aurais jean marie bigard pour de la
blague j'aurais également des nouvelles
de blaise matuidi à vous donner mes
chéris j'aurais également dû bouder pour
une deuxième la guia matthieu delormeau
et gilles verdez qui va à qui mon
arrivée et on aura toutes les vidéos
d'art cas on aura du débat mais chéri
bien sûr vous allez kiffer j'espère que
vous êtes bien on est dans le salon on
est dans votre salon et on essaie de
vous accompagner les chéris vous nous
posez toutes les questions en direct
on y répond merci mes chéris et vous
restez dans le tableau cas où il ya une
grosse question médicale
je vous fais rentrer on sacrée soirée
tintin ta nana na na na table a tout de
suite le titre coté
allez c'est parti vrai ou faux les
boulangeries seront fermés pour éviter
la transmission du coronavirus faut
faire c'est faux les boulangeries vont
même pouvoir est ouverte sept jours sur
sept
grâce à une dérogation du ministère du
travail
c'est la fédération des entreprises de
boulangerie voilà qu'il annonce
aujourd'hui on embrasse tous les
boulangers tous les gens qui travaillent
au milieu boulangerie stick voilà parce
que c'est vrai que là ils travaillent
comme des petits fous comme des petits
pains comme des petits pains génial de
pain complet si on peut un chanteur bain
complet maire s'il a cédé coach sportif
qui parle ouais c'est génial parce que
ça permet aux gens d'avoir une une
sociabilité d'aller acheter leur pain
c'est très important même s'il faut
rester confiné le pain c'est l'aliment
de base c'est l'aliment qui permet de
faire vivre les familles ce qu'on est
dans le salon tu dois te sentir obligé
de dire des trucs mais été aussi cher de
côté je te rassure c'est très important
le décret de seniors ça débarque un
merci sa petite emma qui aujourd'hui à
bercy aller chez chaque français
consomme en moyenne 135 grammes de pain
par jour voilà contre environ 400
grammes dans les années 50 donc on en
consomme moins vous faut un livreur de
pizza peut nous remettre notre commande
en main propre si les mots oui ah bon
c'est faux même si les livraisons de
repas domicile reste autorisée par le
gouvernement
les livreurs de pizza sushi burger n'ont
pas le droit de vous remettre votre
commande dans ma propre payant big up à
planet sushi aussi parce qu'ils ont
décidé d'arrêter pour voilà aussi va la
mettre en sécurité lors leurs employés
voilà ils doivent sonner s'éloigner d'au
moins deux mètres et avoir le sac ouvert
et ont dégagé toutes les consignes ici
ils doivent ensuite vous déposez la
livraison et partir immédiatement sans
avoir de contact direct avec vous bon
c'est très rare que quand vous aviez un
as un mec qui nous livrait aussi des
soucis solide pour les bras vous n'êtes
pas en galoche avec le mec canon +1
c'est très rare que le mec qui te prend
la pizza tu prends la margherita est une
galoche donc bon alors ça peut arriver
vrai ou faux prendre sa voiture pour
aller mettre son plein d'essence c'est
possible ou pas on peut la prendre sa
voiture pour aller mettre son plein
d'essence toujours possible on peut vite
possible
et ouais c'est vrai mais dans certaines
conditions l'approvisionnement des
stations-service continuent d'être
assurées notamment pour les véhicules de
secours les camions de livraison
assurant le ravitaillement des grandes
surfaces
voilà je vous dis et des prix des
carburants s'effondrait donc là c'est le
moment d'aller faire ça c'est bien pour
les gens à voilà allez hop ailleurs
quand même une bonne nouvelle
ouais question alors c'est une histoire
se bouffent les manchots sont les grands
gagnants du court on a vu les manchots
[Rires]
mais bon j aurais pu rien toucher les
noms regarder puisque alors que le corps
la nourrice a entraîné la non la
fermeture de nombreux parcs et aquariums
partout dans le monde
à chicago ils ont autorisé des petits
manchots à se balader tranquillement
dans les allées de l'aquarium pour qu'il
puisse aller visiter en regardez donc
les manchots sont les grands gagnants
regarder
[Musique]
voilà
faire sa valise
[Musique]